hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast advances and modeling human
diseases using induced pluripotent stem
cell-derived cellular models I'm Robert
Castellanos of lab rats and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by cellular dynamics cellular
dynamics international CDI a fujifilm
company as a leading developer and
manufacturer of human cells used in drug
discovery activity testing stem cells
banking and cell therapy development the
technique partners with innovators from
around the world to combine biologically
relevant human cells with the newest
technologies to drive advancements in
medicine and healthier living CBI's
technology offers the potential to
create induced pluripotent stem cells
iPSCs from anyone starting with a
standard blood draw and followed by the
powerful capability to develop into
virtually any cell type in the human
body our proprietary manufacturing
system produces billions of cells daily
resulting in inventoried I sell products
and donor-specific my sell products than
the quantity quality purity and
reproducibility required for drug and
cell therapy development founded in 2004
by dr. James Thompson a pioneer and
human califican stem cell research for
more information please visit cellular
dynamics com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon and the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if a
technical problems hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation though or should make your
problem there's a green Q&A button lower
left
I would like to introduce today's
speakers dr. Kyle Megan and dr. TK
Feaster dr. kailangan an application
scientist at CDI achieved a bachelor's
degree in both physiological psychology
and philosophy modeled by a PhD in
neuroscience from the University of
wisconsin-madison dr. Megan worked
previously with Kimberly car court rush
medical center and the University of
Wisconsin School of Medicine at CBI his
work includes all aspects of CD is
neuronal products including
electrophysiological behavior and
measurements dr. Mankins evaluation are
neural network integration and
manufacturing with the ipsc derived
neuronal cultures has helped push the
field of MEA analysis and
pharmacological screening forward to
disease in a dish essays I'll now turn
it over to dr. minyak for his
presentation hello thank you for the
introduction Robert thank you to CDI and
lab roots in general for organizing this
webinar as Robert just said I'm dr. Kyle
Megan and I will present in the first
part of this webinar titled advances of
modeling human diseases using the
induced pluripotent stem cell-derived
cellular models I will begin by
introducing cellar dynamics
International CDI CDI is a company that
leverages IPSC technology to manufacture
human cells induced pluripotent stem
cells iPSCs provide a platform to
increase our understanding of the
etiology of human disease states CD is
technology highlights how iPSCs can help
spring void and springboard new drug
development of therapies via the disease
in the dish approach we will present
interesting data from disease states
produced by genetically engineered
single gene mutations as well as via and
nate donor samples CDI has optimized
differentiation protocols that convert
iPSCs and the many different cell types
including as will present here today
neurons dopa neurons and cardiomyocytes
but also astrocytes motor neurons
parasites macrophages and the list goes
on and on I've been
so you can visit our website cellular
dynamics com and and see what kind of
cell types we can make for you as
mentions there will be two parts to this
webinar I will talk first about enrolls
these models and then turn the
microphone over and dr. Feaster will
discuss some cardiomyocyte disease
models so in this first part of the
webinar I will discuss some CD eyes
neural cell types including ISIL neurons
and I fold open neurons my agenda
includes presenting data on multiple
disease modeling approaches Alzheimer's
disease Parkinson's disease and epilepsy
i will first however describe our i sell
neuron product which is what i will what
we use to put the mutations into and
assess as far as in rural cultures go
ISIL neurons our human iPS cells
expanded under defined feeder free
conditions and culture to neuronal
differentiation media followed with
neuronal maturation media to induce
differentiated neurons that are then
cryopreserved after 28 30 days totalling
culture ronal cells produced using this
method display appropriate cortical gene
markers including da ch1 fox g1 and otx2
the resulting post awe of these cells
yields a purity of greater than or equal
to eighty-five percent met cortical
neurons measured by high expression of
beta 3 tubulin and negative expression
of nestin by flow cytometry Purcell's
are thus achieved without the need to
sort and this population neurons can
further be defined and tested for
synaptic excitatory or inhibitory
markers including be glue to and V Gant
as well as for the absence of gfap the
result is a product that is eighty-five
percent pure population postmitotic
neurons comprise both gabaergic and
glutamatergic neurons without glia or
any perforating cells using around
only produce appropriate biochemical
markers but also display appropriate
electric physiological markers which can
be captured by a patch clamp or multi
electrode arrays which we will get into
more in a bit CD is my cell neurons
produced in parallel fashion to our ISIL
neurons could be generated engineer and
engineered as well which then allows us
to make point mutations and places where
clinical research has discovered disease
associated mutations it is with this
process that we can produce neurons at
Harbor known as these associated point
mutations culture them up in a dish and
assess utilizing many different
approaches the disease in a dish
phenotype the process of genetically
engineering point mutations in the
healthy donor background is only one
process we can leave utilize to produce
this disease into the dish here at CDA
we also investigated with success to
other processes that result in
phenotypic alterations induced in innate
in the induced process healthy donors
human IPS see their differentiated in
different conditions l biet medium
conditions or hypoxic conditions perhaps
and this alteration differentiation
process can produce phenotypic changes
that can be assessed and compared to
healthy controls another process which
dr. peter will present down in a bit is
the innate where we can take donors from
I'm sorry samples from a donor with a
genetic disease and differentiate these
ipscs using the regular differentiation
protocol and produce and compare them to
the wild-type healthy controlled samples
collectively this is how CDI can
leverage IPSC technology to advance
personalized medicine the neuronal
disease models I will discuss today
however mutations of results in terrible
conditions conditions are not only bad
for the individuals suffering from them
but the public health care system as
well collectively Alzheimer's
Parkinson's and epilepsy disorders
affect over a hundred million people
worldwide and cost of these conditions
in the you
alone is over 300 billion dollars a year
this is obviously need not only for
disease understanding but a major need
for drug development for these
conditions as well one of the major
hurdles within this drug discovery space
is the lack of relative relevant cell
models which we believe here at CDI that
we can start fulfilling with the disease
in the dish approach Alzheimer's disease
currently affects the most amount of
American individuals it is a disease
that is thought to result from plaque
formation developing from aberrant
amyloid beta and how processes these are
both proteins that can be assessed by
already assay kits and things that we do
regularly here at CDI so as mentioned
the ISIL neurons are cryopreserved and
shipped to the customer and and once you
guys have those in hand you can plate
the amount of plates and then use
regular assay kits to assess the amount
of different protein levels in this case
we're looking at amyloid beta human
tower human soluble a PP alpha and we
can see over over increasing number of
cells in the in the culture conditions
we have increasing amounts of the
protein furthermore if we look and
compare the amount of interesting
amyloid beta protein levels we can
compare not only the one through 40
amyloid beta protein but also the the
ratio of 40 to 42 which is been
implicated in in Alzheimer's disease we
can see with a gamma secretase
inhibitors we can see a dose-dependent
decrease in the expression levels of
these proteins which matches what we
would expect to see in the condition
we've generated multiple lines here at
CDI that had interesting effects as far
as Alzheimer's disease ghosts so through
a research in 2012 and a nature
publication there were two variants at
the 673 location of the AP p protein and
two different mutations can either an
alanine to a thymine can be protective
or conversely a 673 V is causative so
this has been discovered and published
on and we here at CDI have put those and
point mutations into our ice on their
own background and we have discovered
that the cells survive in culture and
and thus we can actually investigate the
levels of a PP our amyloid beta protein
interesting ly enough we have discovered
that the levels of one through 40
amyloid beta protein levels is decreased
in the protective condition and
increased in the causative condition
which is what we would expect and then
in either of these cases has disrupted
the ability of the gamma secretase
inhibitors to decrease the levels of
these proteins of interest if you put
this on to the multi-electrode array
platform which is a platform to look at
electrical activity of the cells you you
can take these cells from the
cryopreserve state plate the amount of
these multi-electrode array of platforms
and look at their activity levels
capture their waveforms and capture
their action potentials time frames and
then describe these as far as a mean
firing rate and or look at two
interesting burst parameters including
in this case we looked at Pusan burst
parameters on each individual channel
what we're showing you here on the left
hand side is firing rates in red and
bursting rates in the lower blue for the
wild-type the protective or the
causative conditions for the Alzheimer's
and on the top what we can see is over
days and culture the protective
condition does not change the mean
firing rate compared to the wild-type
with that said the causative condition
is considerably lower in mean firing
rate across the ball
werd and across all days and culture the
bursty raid on the bottom we see at day
8 and day 15 the protective condition
here actually causes an increase in the
Poisson bursting parameters whereas the
causative is decreased compared to
control collectively what the suggest is
is a we have a protective and a
causative sample for Alzheimer's disease
here that we can make in and have ready
and cryopreserved vials furthermore
these can be assessed for the amyloid
beta protein levels and they had a
display altered electrical activity
levels for the human Parkinson's model
that I'll present in the moment I'll
first introduced the I sell dope in
neurons which again similar to the ICL
neurons is a is a is a neuronal product
however in this case it's a midbrain
dopaminergic neuron that expresses go
over ninety percent coexpression for fox
a2 and alum x1 and over eighty percent
for th which is tyrosine hydroxylase
these neurons express the appropriate
markers compared to the human
substantial Niagara cells and these
cells when placed in the multi-electrode
array platform over days and cultures
beginning with day six and then and then
going all the way to three weeks in
culture today 20 they start to organize
themselves and create large synchronous
bursting behaviors this can be captured
in a functional assay to look at a
velocity graph which is an all-points
histogram of the action potentials
across all the electrodes and we can see
that there's hyper synchronous bursting
behaviors that usually max out about 400
500 Hertz in their in their hyper
synchronous moment the engineered
parkinsonian line that we have is an
alpha synuclein a 53 T mutation which is
an autosomal dominant early-onset
Parkinson's
[Music]
mutation this has been investigated with
many publications is one of the most
well-known parkinsonian mutations and in
the neurons that we have made this point
mutation in display multiple attributes
which would be in line with the idea
that this is altering dopaminergic
activity the gene expression levels show
that first and foremost there is an
increase gene expression signal for
alpha synuclein which is what we would
expect it is in these neurons compared
to control interestingly enough the
tyrosine hydroxylase and don't but
decarboxylase measures are both
decreased suggesting that the production
of dopamine in these neurons is actually
lower than normal and furthermore the
catabolism compte gene expression level
is actually higher than normal
suggestion that dopamine is to getting
degraded quicker as well both of these
kind of push the idea there's less
dopamine being organized within these
dopant ions which is matching that which
the research field sees in the
functional assay on the right hand side
with the velocity graph and the all
points histogram of synchronous bursting
behaviors well we can see as we can see
two differences in the culture which is
with the same number of electrodes we
actually have decreased Burstein rate
but during this hyper synchronous moment
we can actually see it the burst
intensity is about four times more
intense than the regular condition
jumping into one of these publications a
little bit deeper what we can see is
that in figure 2 of the paper from
nnamani increased expression of
alpha-synuclein reduces neurotransmitter
release by inhibiting synaptic vesicle
recovering after exocytosis and figure 2
it describes it as decreased field epsps
which kind of matches the
idea of our decreased bursting rate and
but interestingly enough it also has
increased paired-pulse facilitation
which suggests that during during
activity you can actually induce more X
potentials at once this is also
recapitulated in our functional meas a
with the alpha synuclein 853 T dopamine
neurons the phenomenon is further
exemplified with the FD SS calcium ass a
system which ish describes larger
calcium oscillations and then earlier
onset as far as staying culture goes and
then last but not least the altered
spare respiratory capacity that we see
by assessment via seahorse my toe stress
test shows that there's altered levels
of of respiratory spare capacitance in
these neurons collectively the the
differential gene expression and the
altered functional North America past
tense measures of these cells is right
in line with the idea that this is a
parkinsonian model and a good disease in
the dish model to study this mutation
the Epilepsy lines that we've
investigated and in this case I will
present three different lines as a case
ENT one mutation and scn1a mutation and
a GABA a gamma 2 r43 Q mutation that
these all conferred different epilepsies
in the clinic all of these neurons can
be plated the same as their ice on iran
counterparts controls and and they all
show good growth and dendritic outgrowth
but one of the things that we've been
able to capture using an inca site zoom
evaluation of neurite outgrowth is at
the KC and t1 and scn1a neurons both
show increased knee right length and the
right outgrowth sorry knee right length
and knee right branch point
compared to their control conditions
this is suggestive of more dendritic
outgrowth and more synaptic availability
which could be a measure of epilepsy and
it we also have done obviously
functional measures with with these
neurons after all epilepsy is a brain
electrical disturbance and therefore
measuring the electrical activity of
these neurons is crucial on the MEA what
we have discovered as if we capture the
waveforms of the case ENT one mutated
neurons we can see an increase to
repolarization and an increased after
hyperpolarization which is something
that we would expect to find in this
mutated Neron type furthermore if we use
an anti-epileptic agent in this case
published treatment of this condition
with quinidine we can see that it
actually quinidine attenuates the
repolarization and after
hyperpolarization increases we've seen
with these waveforms on the post on
bursting parameter level we can see that
the KMT 1 neurons display increased
intensity values and decreased first
durations compared to their wild-type
counterparts again this is this
increased burst intensity level is a is
a concept of an increased electrical
signal suggesting an epileptic phenotype
the same can be said for the scn1a
neuron which is also kind of more of a
gas on form of neuronal manipulation for
epilepsy whereas they are 43 q neuron
which is which is a mutation in the GABA
a receptor and more like taking the
breaks off version of epilepsy we don't
see an increase in the number in the
intensity value of the bursts but what
we do see that we see twice as many
excitatory bursts occurring one cell
type that I haven't mentioned yet that
we do have is the ISL gluten Iran's
which is a very excited tory version of
the isil neurons which synchronously
bursts and culture if we mix the isil
neurons with the
CMT one mutated epileptic neurons what
we can see is we see a an increase in
the synchronous bursting rate of the
culture something that again would be
considered epileptic and then if we
treat this again with the quinidine
condition in the same well we can see
that the bursting starts to ameliorate a
little bit so we're treating with Aedes
and getting the decreased results that
we would expect so the highlights of the
epileptic conditions we have is
increased knee right outgrowth epileptic
functional phenotypes and then again the
treatment by the Aedes which appears to
be able to attenuate the condition
slightly I appreciate your attention and
then I will give this back over to the
moderator Robert and then listen to TK
Feaster's conversation thank you thank
you so very much doctor for the
beginning part of this presentation and
I would like to introduce dr. TK Feaster
for his portion dr. TK feature is a
field application scientist at Solar
Dynamics international dr Feaster
received his PhD in pharmacology in 2015
from Vanderbilt University for his work
using human induced pluripotent stem
cell-derived cardiomyocytes to
investigate cardiaca excitation
contraction coupling dr. Fisher join CDI
as a technical application scientist
working in the applications group where
we served as a primary support liaison
for cardiac products as well as showing
responsibility for in lab applications
development I'll now turn it over to dr.
Feaster for his presentation thank you
for that introduction today I'm going to
be talking about human IPS derive
disease models for hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy this is an agenda of the
top first I will go over some of the
background on human induced pluripotent
stem cell-derived cardiomyocytes and
introduce the ISL cardiomyocytes next I
will talk about some of the disease
disease modeling approaches employed at
CDI and then I will give you some
round on hypertrophic cardiomyopathy or
HCM really highlighting 2k examples one
of an induced example in one of an
innate example human induced pluripotent
stem cell-derived cardiomyocytes
recapitulate many aspects of native
cardiomyocyte biology so these are human
cardiomyocytes that give you access to
human biology and vitro particularly
these cells display intact excitation
contraction coupling this ranges from
electrical activity at the membrane
being translated to intracellular
calcium handling with intact
calcium-induced calcium release in tax
our circle plasmic reticulum and also
intact calcium and Maya filament
interactions that drive mechanical
beating and contractility the ICL
cardiomyocytes are a trial preserve cell
that's ready to use this is greater than
ninety-five percent pure cardiomyocytes
based on cardiac troponin t expression
these cells represent a consistent and
reproducible source of human
cardiomyocytes for in vitro assessment
including disease modeling toxicity
testing and target validation I'm just
going to revisit this slide for a moment
dr. Megan went over some of the
engineered examples for some of our
general disease models I'll be focusing
on the induced example and an eight
example in the induced example the ICL
cardiomyocytes are exposed to different
conditions to really bring out the HCM
phenotype and the innate example the
blood is taken from a patient with HCM
that is reprogrammed to IPS cells
they'll so that's been differentiated to
cardiomyocytes and studies in the lab
for the innate example I'll go into some
of the characterization of the
functional characterization of the
mutation and for the induced example
I'll give a high-level snapshot of the
capabilities and utility of this line so
what is HCM a cm is classically
characterized with preserved systolic
function and impaired diastolic
dysfunction this affects 1 in 500 people
and is accompanied by increasing
occurrence of a rhythmic events and can
lead to sudden cardiac death HCM is
characterized with thickening of the
heart muscle here you can see in the
diseased heart the hardest thicker
particularly the septum relative to the
normal heart HCM can be caused by many
sarcomeric mutations in particular the
beta myosin heavy chain mutation
accounts for over fifty percent of HCM
cases this mutation this mutations in
this gene really have a severe phenotype
these can be studied in vitro by looking
at the structure or mythology of the
cells looking at changes themselves
sides and reorganization as well as
changes in gene expression increases in
fetal gene expression as well as the
increased expression of beta myosin
heavy changed to the Alpha myosin heavy
chain ratio this can be assessed
functionally by looking at changes in
calcium handling electrical activity or
contractile properties
so now I'm showing you one of the innate
on site one of the induced examples
these cells are played it as a mono
layer and exposed to end up building one
to really bring out that cardiac
hypertrophy phenotype here I'm showing
the cells being stained without back
tending to assess cell size you can see
that as you increase the concentration
of in 2001 there's a
concentration-dependent increase in the
total cxl area showing that these cells
are getting larger we also looked at the
f-actin f2g actin ratio to look at
cytoskeletal rearrangement here we're
showing the cells stained and this is
quantified below as you increase the
concentration of endothelin-1 there's a
concentration-dependent increase in the
FG actin ratio we also looked at the
increase in the fetal gene program we
can get being teeth or brain natural
rate except I'd we've stained the cells
with Daffy and blue and BMP and green or
antibody for being seeing green you can
see that the induced sales have
increased expression and this is
quantified below where you have an
increased concentration dependent
increase in BMP expression or cell so
these data really shows that you can use
the ICL cardiomyocytes and manipulate
the environment to look at cardiac
hypertrophy looking for possibly
compounds that will induce hypertrophy
kind of out there might inhibit
hypertrophy or just really trying to
understand the biology of how the cells
are becoming hypertrophy
so that's we're going to change gears
and look at one of the examples of the
innate hypertrophic cardiomyopathy and
this is the my cell line that is derived
from a patient with a are for 3q
mutation this is a substitution that
switches the arginine to glutamine and
panel a I'm showing the control is l
cardiomyocytes expressing greater than
ninety-five percent cardiac troponin t
and we also have the diseased cells that
are comparable these cells are also have
comparable viability as the control
cells as well as plating efficiency in
penalty I'm showing you a representative
bright field image of the cells just to
give you an idea of what they look like
in culture one of the first things we
did was look at the BNP BNP expression
in the baseline BMP expression into
myself for 403 q cells so you can see
that there's increased BMP expression
this is done by standing the cells with
the antibody for BMP you can see the in
red there's increased expression
relative to the control cells we also
looked at some of the gene expression
for this beta 2 alpha myosin heavy chain
ratio this is known to be increased in
failing hearts or ACM hearts and you can
see that in vitro these sales have
increased expression increase ratio of
beta myosin to optimize output myosin
heavy chain ratio so next we're going to
look at some little more in depth at the
gene profile here we're showing an
example of the induced cardiac
hypertrophy relative to control and this
is a panel of genes known to be involved
in cardiac hypertrophy and in panel B
I'm showing the hour for 3q sample
relative control relative to control for
the same panel of jeans you can see that
some of the genes are upregulated and
some are downregulated in both cases the
trends are consistent across the induced
and the
Nate samples however the induced sample
has a greater increase or decrease of
relative to the control so this is a
more pronounced or robust phenotype
relative to the are for 3q samples so
the next thing we wanted to do was to
look a little more closer at the
functional consequences of this are for
3q mutation on the first things we did
was look at the beating activity and
this is assessed on the excelence by
looking at the changes in impedance and
these experiments the cells are plated
as a monolayer and an e plate and in a
panel a I'm showing the control I sell
cardiomyocytes representative impedance
morphology you can see that they're
stable beating in these cells in the are
for 3q cells this beating is actually
slowed these cells are beating much
slower than these control cells this is
quantified in table B you can see that
the art for 3q cells beat at around
eight beats per minute while the control
cells in these conditions are beating at
around 27 beats per minute the amplitude
of each cell type was the same however
the beat rate variation was different
the art for 3q cells had increased beat
rate variation relative to the control
cells this was important because this is
consistent with what you would see in
vivo that these sales or patients with
this mutation have increased a rhythmic
like activity activity or unstable
beating next we want to look at the
electrical activity I've just showed you
an example of the impedance looking at
the beating behavior this is now in more
of a direct measure of electrical
activity using the MEA in these
experiments the cells are played it as a
high concentration dot over the
recording electrodes and the electric
activity is measured in panel a i'm
showing the control i sell
cardiomyocytes representative filled
potential morphology and in be i'm
showing these are for 3q mutation the
representative fill particular ratio
you can see that consistent with the
impedance measurement this beading is
slowed relative to control this is
quantified in panel B where we're
looking at the field potential duration
for the eye for 3q sample in green in
the control cells in blue you can see
that the art for 3q cells have a
prolonged field potential duration
relative to control cells this is
consistent with a lower beat frequency
relatives of control cells and these
cells also display increase occurrence
of beating irregularity or rhythmic
events as shown in the beat rate
variation so this is just a independent
experiment that really confirms the
impedance experiment the same result as
decrease be rate and increase a rhythmic
like activity in dock for 3q cells
relative to control now we're going to
change gears a little bit and look at
some of the calcium handling properties
of these cells these are two
publications that have shown using IPS
derived cardiomyocytes they investigated
beta myosin heavy chain mutations these
mutations are different than the art for
3q mutation one is the r44 2g and the
others are 6 63 h mutation both of these
mutations as have has a severe phenotype
also landed all showed in their paper in
2013 that the ACM sell both a look that
had a differential response to calcium
for example they looked at the better
pain which is a known calcium channel
blocker and they looked at the
effectiveness feta team on betrayed and
they show that as they increase the
concentration of the better fiend
there's a concentration-dependent
decrease in betrayed however with the
HTM cells this is shift this
concentration response curve is shifted
to the right suggesting that these cells
are less sensitive that it takes more
than a better pinion to really stop the
beating this is consistent with the Maya
filament calcium sensitization
hypothesis for HCM we looked at this
with the art for 3 q's I for 3 q cells
and we saw the same response we want to
look a little more closer at the effect
of calcium channel block on irregular
beating as well as the effects of
mechanical overload here we're using
verapamil which is another calcium
channel blocker and these experiments
were looking at calcium handling by
plating the cells of them in a monolayer
and loading them with the calcium
sensitive died in panel a I'm showing
the calcium transients for the control
cells you can see the cells have stable
regular calcium transients however in
the hour for 3q cells these calcium
calcium transients are more irregular in
slower consistent with the electrical
activity in the beating activity
observed from under me a as well as the
impedance these data are quantified in
be where you can see in green the
control cells have a stable beating at
around 30 beats per minute however the
diseased cells looking at the calcium
handling have a reduced betrayed they
also display the direct the irregular
beating or increase of rhythmic activity
so we want to see what the effect would
be abusing of Rapa meal at calcium
channel blocker on these cells in the
control cells verapamil has little
effect on the beating behavior however
in the are 43 q cells they restore the
beating behavior and eliminate the
irregular beating activity there's a
quantified indeed you can see there in
the green panels the control
cardiomyocytes as well as the rapa mill
control cardiomyocytes there's
negligible effects however when you
expose the disease are for 3q
cardiomyocytes to verapamil the bead
period is increased nearly the baseline
and the irregular beating is reduced
the next thing we wanted to do was to
look at the effects of mechanical
overload in this experiments were using
the same calcium handling experiments
the same calcium handling diet where we
have to control cells and their
spontaneously beating then they undergo
a pasting protocol where we increase the
pacing 2.5 hurts and then stop pacing
and allow the cells to recover then
increase the face into one hurt and stop
pacing an allowed ourselves to recover
then 1.5 hurts stop pacing into hers and
stop pacing you can see that at each
event when the pacing is stopped the
cells begin to spontaneously be together
however when you look at the diseased
cells the are for 3q cells at the lower
conf at the lower frequencies of pacing
the sales recover when the when the
pacing is stopped however when you
increase to these higher frequencies
11.5 and two Hertz once you stop pacing
the cell do not recover so this is a
distinct phenotype that's shown in these
cells we looked at the effect of
verapamil and we showed their rapid
Miller versus effect and allow the are
for 3q cells to begin beating again
spontaneously after pacing at these high
frequencies it stopped so this is an
example of a unique phenotype to these
cells that can be reversed with chemical
inhibition of calcium channels and one
could use as possibly to look at a
phenotypic screens for compounds that
will have a similar effect
this slide is to illustrate how we have
been trying to really enable the entire
research community to have access to
different disease types through our
banking efforts the first being think
first IPS cells being banked in 2010 and
then in 2015 approximately 800 donors
being banks and then currently
approximately two thousand donors and
the projection for 2018 is around 8000
and these are across different disease
backgrounds from neurological disorders
and cardiac disorders of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy dilated cardiomyopathy
and some neurological disorders and some
of them are disorders that affect the
PATA sites and different systems of the
body so this is the summary slide
summarizing both dr. mangas presentation
in mind dr. Megan went over some of the
IPS derived neuronal disease models for
Alzheimer's Parkinson's and epilepsy and
these were both these are all engineered
examples I went over some of the cardiac
examples for hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
and induced example in an innate example
and then I also touch a little touched a
little bit on some of the banking
efforts to allow the research community
access to these cell types with that I
will pass it back over to the moderator
and thank you for your attention well
thank you for that informative
presentation doctors before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience chatters to make questions you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window so
we do have our first question here have
you investigated other induces of kali
actic hypertrophy yes no that's a good
question we are we have looked at other
inducers to really induce and bring out
that cardiac hypertrophy phenotype we
have looked at isoproterenol
as well as phenylephrine and all of
those that we've tested have shoulder
response showing a response however the
endothelium was the most robust response
in our essay so some of the other
inducers are also will work however the
workflow needs to be adapted a little
bit well thank you our next question can
this be applied to studying m.e that
affects over 1 million in us perhaps 17
million worldwide it has not FDA
approved diagnostics of treatments can
you form natural killer cells B cells
diagonal cell models major process this
year an mecfs biochem but need models
that's a really good question we can
produce immune and glia cells from ipscs
in all of these cells and then the ISIL
neuron product itself are very calm
competent for infection unlike primary
neurons suggesting researchers would be
able to produce an Emmy in a dish
disease model from these samples thank
you with your meeting protein expression
experiments are you also reducing the
endogenous protein via RNA cast 9 etc
the age of the 3t mutation is in the
genome and not and overexpressed so all
the models that we have shown result
from genomic differences and our an
endogenous expression change for the
mutant protein not something that we've
further manipulated as far as a type of
up or down regulation goes thank you and
can either speakers have examples
involving a combination of both innate
and induced state of ie environmental
insult onto cells from a disease patient
yes this is actually a very good
question i don't have any examples of
this however that is
where the field is going and the utility
of these cells that you can have the
different disease backgrounds and then
expose them to different environment of
environmental factors so that's
something that we definitely would like
to look up I don't have any example of
anything in literature to reflect that
yep how likely is I see actually you
derive disease model mimicking a real
busy the the idea of a model is that
it's a model it might not be exactly
producing the phenotype that we see in
the human shoot whole body condition but
nonetheless alterations and expression
levels or changes in in respiratory
behavior or activity levels can be
compared from the healthy control and
then investigated in that fashion all
right thank you so very much looks like
Hannah might have one last question is
there a correlation between firing
frequency repertory the possibility in
general meaning do neurons with lower
frequency have higher respiratory keep
capacity and the a5 3t neurons a disease
associated phenomenon a really good
question and obviously something that
needs to be investigated more and here's
an example of you know the model
definitely recapitulate the human
condition in a lot of aspects of
Parkinson's we see in the human
condition and other models we see a
lowered spare respiratory capacity in
the cells that we've created with the
apt 3t mutation we actually see a
significantly increased spare
respiratory capacity over this is very
early in culture and as we know
a longitudinal disorder so maybe if we
kept the cells and cultured for a really
extended period of time similar to the
disease condition we could see but but
nonetheless the the altered respiratory
capacitance of the cells shows that
there is definitely a phenotype and his
worth investigation and obviously
something that we would like to look
into in the future thank you can you
rescue any of you mutant phenotypes with
overexpression
so for this question I don't have a
precise answer for it depending on the
mutation and the disease so I talked a
little bit about the beta myosin heavy
chain mutation I'm not sure they
overexpressing that would rescue that
phenotype I don't think that's been
looked at in the literature one might
try to reverse the mutation by
genetically altering it but um I didn't
either no thank you so very much for
that um longer some final comments
doctors do you have any final comments
before we conclude today's presentation
obviously it's a snapshot in the future
the personalized medicine space is in
need of drug discovery and directional
research and using these models of the
engineered and the innate can maybe give
us a better glimpse into what's
occurring with these disorders and
diseases and allow us to enter that
personalized medicine space with a
little bit more direction and effort
well thank you so very much just want to
thank our sponsor for today cellular
dynamics for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
made 2017 you'll receive an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to for that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed two days
the live event until next time goodbye